ce qui me frappe comme témoin bientôt
noël et moi mais voilà ce soir sur elle
et tout paris vous avez une petite tour
eiffel paris sis au quartier de la
défense dans le coin on à montmartre qui
est juste là bas et on est présent
aujourd'hui donc au dernier étage pour
parler d'eux se dit pour parler du
xperia x3 quelque chose à voir vous
allez voir il ya des voitures il ya des
smartphones tout ça se mélange un petit
peu regardé ça ensemble
donc là sony nous inviter dans le pur
esprit du drive-in américain c'est à
dire des voitures avec un tig z3 qui est
positionnée au niveau du rétroviseur
c'est assez marrant du coup vous avez
toutes les voitures qui sont en ligne et
à regarder
elles sont toutes alignées directement
ici et chacun dans sa bagnole regarde
sur son exode 3 son petit fils lauriad
une étude rics pas mal de choses et de
la musique donc là on est dans une mini
sur les veines de sony l'idée c'est de
faire un drive-in donc ayant et sociale
vers un smartphone exactement
on peut se faire un peu driving
américain du coup on si on pouvait
repartir avec une voiture plutôt quinté
plus et ça coûte ça changerait c'est
assez compliqué au dernier étage la
fosse jeter mais là du coup on a le
ballon fait dans five i'll be your way
c'est vraiment quand on manque un peu de
muscu ce que tu vois à
voilà ça drague tafer driving patins à
roulettes sauvian lee rose le petit pop
corn
ne changez rien c'est parfait on laisse
la dame tranquille annonce qu'on a du
coeur
[Musique]
boire ou conduire il faut choisir j'ai
pas de permis en hauteur là tu crains
semi nous régale déjà avec un écran
bravia oled qualité de ouf sur ses
smartphones
en plus de ça il ya corner musique ici
avec le nouveau casque au nom antique ou
imprononçable l'anil dedans ça je le
retiens m/h 1000x m3 gt ou fax au casque
c'est la réduction web et y en a qui
disent que c'est 35 pardon à attention
il faut bien m'écouter quand je viens
les effets spéciaux
alors il le plus monté sur c'est le
concurrent pardon du qu c 35 certains
disent même qu'il est mieux ce qui sera
testée moi je t'aime moi non peu sur les
oreilles la favorite écoute pas joué
comme ça sur mer
tu fais ta feignante aa
du coup tu as gagné quand même de
visiter non mais c'est parce que j'ai
plus de place dans la voiture commence à
se battre on a fait dans son père et je
suis plus le tien tu veux du pop com
non non j'en ai plein non mais tout
s'est pas fait un stage était du ça mais
aussi salim tu as vu trois pasqua bain
il est pas mal déjà il a été relookée
j'aurai ce qui est pas mal on attend
d'eux à l'air assez performant il a
l'air après back home dambach il faut le
tester pour voir un peu ce qu'il à
l'endroit et puis un à mon avis là il
peut tenir ses promesses
moi je pense que potentiellement les
ardeurs encore un très bon smartphone en
tous les cas ils ont dit au niveau
lifestyle et cetera il avait travaillé
sur le truc way est effectivement
jusqu'au bout nous voir
on a quelque chose d'un peu sympa
au niveau look
ce qui n'est pas négligeable pour moi
moi la tête à tête féminin tout ce joli
oui il faut que ce soit dab aussi jolie
pas juste superbe et reprenons donc
voilà on est pas mal je suis pas la
seule
tu as tellement way et le truc c'est
plutôt sympa c'est le positionnement
tarifaire voyez que toutes les
maçonneries 800 euros bien voilà
par rapport à la concurrence qui
continue d'augmenter a prévu plus en
plus sa qualité de l'écran je pense
qu'elle est plutôt pas mal qui ont
exactement
il ya plein de choses qui sont bien au
niveau de l'écran avec ce système de
vibration quand je regarde des films qu
est ce qu il yad autres parce qu'ils ont
mis un processeur de traitement dont en
gros à un célébre alors sony bravia dans
ton dans cet écran et c'est exactement
ça c'est ce qu'ils disent et la province
c'est la promesse là on va voir
maintenant en tout cas on est plutôt
chaud patate un bois c'est plutôt son
parc ce qui fut la pop corn carré
[Musique]
donc là l'idée ce soir c'est un petit
peu partagé l'expérience driving
américains ont tous fait vraiment un
focus sur la qualité de l'écran pour
sony écran bravia oled vous le redis
encore ce smartphone l'exacte 3 je
l'aurais d'ici quelques jours dans les
mains pour le tester donc on va pouvoir
aller beaucoup plus loin au niveau de
l'écran vraiment ce qui donne qualité
sonore appareil photo on sait que sony
équipe vraiment beaucoup de capteurs du
marché au niveau de la photo sur les
smartphones j'aime beaucoup cette
couleur que c'est vraiment très très
bien réussi extrêmement bien réussi
alors bon là on a vraiment ses
compétiteurs mari pourrait tout c'est
quand même tu es dans lifestyle
l'instant ils n'ont pas exactement après
une citronnade quoi toi non j'ai pas
encore pris ah ouais tu devras du monde
ça monte dessus pour moi
je viens du coup remet en jeu 10 peuvent
commencer à laisser parfait mais là je
vois pas qui c'est
et pour une fois tu vois pas que oui
mais pourtant les frites étaient super
chaude et ça va devenir très nécessaire
oui donc je vous invite à vous abonner
on reste connectés et puis là on va
partir parce que on va filer chez welch
qui vit
mathieu m'a gentiment invité ce soir
pour aller parler sur le plateau de
andromaque donc je mettrai le lien en
bas c'est une franchement cool merci
mathieu donc bon sony je vous laisse
pour ce soir mais d'ici quelques jours
on reparle du higgs est de 3 je vous
invite dès sur vous restez connectés
puis vous vous restez parce que j'emmène
avec moi on va y avoir quatre hôtels est
comme ça qu on fait tout d'un coup on y
va ah ouais non mais au genre l'émission
voulait pas la fermer
bien sûr précis attendait un message à
faire passer on a une émission à tourner
dans deux dans une heure et demie on
dévoie 22h30 exactement sur watchmen est
acquis cette can a un je ne sais pas
ressemble à la mienne car sam à la
tienne tu me piquer alors je vais
emprunter nuance tu pourra la récupérer
sur e-bay et tu pourras tu es un vrai là
on a à peu près
une heure pour préparer l'émission donc
on va préparer tout ce qui est visuel
pour l'émission ouais et après le boss
de match ils arrivent belgy way et nous
fait nous asseoir et il va régler les
caméras qui sont motorisées tout ça avec
eux il n'y a pas de caméra y'a pas de
caméra match que le film est bien sûr
voilà tu peux filmer il n'y a pas de
souci d'un pur
allez on se retrouve pour l'émission
avec mon swing juste après tant
d'épreuves
l' écoute alors je suis toujours stressé
à brest depuis la turquie prépare un
matos ya même pas préparé le bateau
d'exactement mathieu tu déconnes boxing
jury enfin live bon ça va te plaît tout
à fait prêt alors tu m'as dit que tu
avais prévu les mocassins
mais oui ça voilà la vérité son superbe
ouverture de vaud cuir de veau pleine
fleur on s'en va chercher on est prêt ça
va on va essayer de pas dire de jason
journée surpris oui bon ça va et atari
j'adore beaucoup pour toujours waouh
on a alors là il est quelque chose comme
comme 21h avec un sac tu sais que je
dors à cette heure-ci à l'ehpad à cet or
si on me couche je dors déjà à l'ehpad à
cette heure ci en fait en plus salées
traite simplement parce qu'on la regarde
et 39 minutes mais moi j'ai cinq ans du
sol moi j'ai 50 sur matic watch pro est
il proche de l'influent même pas alors
bon je crois que ce soir on va parler de
rico bien sûr ce sera pas admis qu et on
parle de pas mal de produits aux ponots
aux normes éthiques celui-là mon mieux
faire un pari de est dû qu on a vu tout
à l'heure la le xperia x7 3roam y était
il ya quelques instants voilà et on va
parler bien évidemment ça va tu es chaud
ouais ouais
sur une encoche hanter les à midi en
fait d'un petit coucou à la caméra de
films de coucou à la caméra et oui on
retrouvera une petite vidéo sur la
chaîne de monsieur greu et qui nous
filmé en direct c'est une inception
désole l'émission dans l'émission c'est
sur exactement
exactement bon alors les gars bien et
bah écoute très bien j'ai beaucoup parlé
oui entend pas beaucoup entendu entendu
malheureusement c'était magnifique
c'est super c'est génial par son groupe
the scene ouais bravo les gars va gérer
ces familles à larache et nora bon très
bon ben voilà donc les habits offert une
prochaine fois le plaisir prochaine fois
jamais dans le champagne sabré le
champagne en direct les quincailleries
cacahuètes et les cacahuètes bon merci
beaucoup merci pour ta bile sur moi je
suis resté connecté yes bisous
[Musique]